okay so I'll just say right now for the
next couple you're probably guess you
robbed in these because the power went
out my house and again these are shot
early so by the time you see this you'll
probably know the nostalgia critic was
wait it was the Lord of rings one three
is like filming three of these in a row
yeah we're just doing a couple he's
they're all like you know the power just
came on but I'm still importing the
footage of war the rage of this season I
will to like I will totally try to get
in as many episodes of the season as pop
yeah so I mean so for the next year
we're just running through avatars right
now while I'm importing the Lord a range
footage so um with that said we have the
headband okay kind of weird title the
more I think about it I'll it was the
name of my first GarageBand which is
very obviously Footloose I think I'm a
bit but I seize of I shades like Star
Wars you little bit something nobody
brought moves
this is quickly what works blood with
firebending I mean it's it's a lot
smarter than Footloose
I don't care let me about against Muslim
Oh publicist bucket stupid and yell at
the kids love it
any help right down to the ad sound
effects though I mean even though that's
more Speed Racer here but okay going
inspect again okay it's like we just get
rid of them in the first season but now
we're bringing down on suspected - yeah
just overwhelming I'm like um I'm
fucking ace that no matter I'll ask I
know it's the style I just gave it it's
my own going the more classic eighties
sound effect so you can get in any
cartoon the better cut those dumbass
sound effects I just and I know it's the
thing I know that the anime style I know
that's just how it works it just dried
to me oh oh dog so violent dog okay okay
so we have this episode called the
headband which is actually again I if
you were to tell me where do you think
the season was gonna go what do you
think the next episodes go along I would
not have predicted that and it's
actually a pretty clever turn because at
first you you don't suspect you wouldn't
expect that was gonna happen but then on
top of that it's actually kind of a
smart move because as he says he's
actually finding out about the
by Rene fees and basically hiding right
out in the open yeah I love and I love
to use the idea of a one hundred twenty
one hundred twelve year old kid who has
all these superpowers just sitting
around in school and like my favorite
line is like oh you must be one of those
popular kids and I've heard so much
about birds I've heard so much about
just like there's like nothing fazes him
it's like the kid tries to kick his ass
and Aang's like okay like you know he
just dodges a bin because he knows like
he could totally kill this guy in an
instant and again I I like those
instances where you have someone who's
really kind really nice it kind of a
passive is I mean he will fight what he
needs to but you know we'll try to avoid
violence and he's actually becoming more
popular than the really tough violent
kids because he's just smarter and
didn't fight him either he just dodged
him yeah I mean I love that I love how
that can actually get him more friends
and make him more popular you know by
just being really smart and doing his
own thing um for the most part it's it's
a good episode i i got sit through some
of this stuff where again i kind of go
oh that that's for the kids okay like
Sokka guitar dressing up like the
parents come on that was heavy we're
having to dance at the Michael I this is
like prom night now I think this is
straight-up Footloose and the grounds
commander my most unorthodox and stuff
but it's I mean it's done well enough I
mean it works well enough not quite to
the point where I'm like this is
unbelievably stupid but at the same time
I'm going this is kind of a ten-year-old
I know and that's gonna do I'll were
shorter than happy feet this did it in
24 minutes it's economical but you did I
don't know it's good to have an episode
like this cuz again it's nice to see an
come in and he teaches these kids who
are not allowed to have much of a
childhood he gives him a little bit of a
childhood a he allows them to rebel a
little bit to you know at a point where
kids need to rebel and it's important
and that's why I think the episode does
work it's just again you have to sort of
sit through this stuff like oh we're
doing that
Oh bad cliche all right well I think
you're wrong I think there's more going
on in this episode than you're giving it
credit for
I mean it's it's good and and it works
um and honestly I don't know what I
would fix if I had to go in and fix it
it's or if I get acknowledged you're
kind of out no I acknowledge it needs to
be here it's I don't know I I don't know
what I think that someone Zuko's good
it's still really good not so
surprisingly uncle Aaron doesn't talk
that much I honestly I it is funny
because in retrospect now because we
know what happened to Mako it makes
sense but it's a really brilliant move
it it's the oh really works it really
works as a story that he would give him
the silent treatment it's all go in it
also it also gives you a buffer zone so
that you have a few episodes to not
listen to mako's original voice that way
you are not gonna be like whoa what the
hell tell me different gates the guy
that got to replace him is somebody I
think was doing bit roles in the show
already does a really good impression
it's actually like really good I haven't
heard it yet but um you actually you
probably have I'm almost positive
because Mako died in somewhere near the
end of the second okay so he did a few
pickups I'm almost positive this guy did
a few pickup said there's a lot of times
and it's no big season one it's still
just slightly different enough cuz how
how do you get a voice like Makos it's
just there's a lot of times where I was
saying that you know either he was sick
or in a different mood or a cold or
something or this is a different voice
at you but all the time it's just a one
and auto cuz if you just can't replicate
a 60 something-year-old Japanese but it
you know it it's just different enough
that by giving you that gap you'll
forget particularly if you're watching
this Weekly I mean we're watching it
daily yeah or I've watched it daily now
um it gives you enough of a gap that you
kind of forgot exactly how his voice
sounds so you don't flip out it's
horrible to say so I'm really good
erection on top of that Mako kind of
dive at just the right time in terms of
the show
because you have you know zoom you're
going to die and we never want to see
how first we though it was going it that
it it's clear that was happening no
matter what and it's fortuitous that it
happened when it yes because he had a
knot in the middle of season Warner's
yeah because Zuko has betrayed his uncle
and his uncle is giving him the silent
treatment and you know usually I'm not a
fan of silent treatment but you kind of
understand it here because the uncle has
done everything has given everything for
his nephew and I you know I've been to
Manila Tech you know he he can't even
say piss he's disappointed I think he's
just disappointed to the fam yeah the
soy-based like there is nothing I could
do he feels like it's his failure as
well yeah and yeah and Zuko comes asking
for more advice and it's like which is
still based on capturing the avatar
which is what I love
yeah I don't think he'll ever answer
he's like I need your you know I need
your help uncle I need your help and
he's not answering because he knows well
all you want is help capturing Aang and
I I'm not in LA on top of that I I think
he finally realizes to because the uncle
would never leave him alone he served he
gave him a his space for a bit but even
then he still followed now is like no
you need to face this alone you know you
made your choice now you really have to
think about what you have and what
you're gonna do about it because yeah
he's given everything for him and I
think the seemed a great buddy
dig it and I really like that I really
like the moment when you know Zuko he
turns around he leaves and again it like
what you say it didn't show the anger
shows the disappointment and ease it
just has that one tear flow down space
and again that's just made Mako pride
damage suka that's just as powerful as
anything you go written for him so
whether or not it was intentional to
have him be quiet originally or they did
because he passed really my it ties in
beautifully so ya know I thought was
very well done the episode itself I
thought it was really brilliant because
this is something you don't see when you
have most cartoon shows with an enemy
yeah they try to
that you don't get to see children on
the other side you don't get to see
their daily lives you don't get to see
the fact that they're being
indoctrinated with cellphone calls
interrupting my great speech I miss how
you finish I'm to continue anyway um
yeah you don't get to see these things I
mean there's a great lesson here about
basically understanding the other the
person that you're calling an enemy and
what Ang's learning is like these kids
aren't exactly like me and some ways the
worse off because they're just being fed
this horseshit you know from a very
early age and they can't dance they
can't have any sort of sense of fun
they're trained to just worship the
state you know and Sokka and Katara's
have such a hatred for the Fire Nation I
mean when her case that played out even
more in later episodes but Sokka - he's
always like you know those
fire-breathing monsters those you know
and I think Aang's proving a very
important point they're not monsters at
all you know they're just kids they're
being trained live with us a little bit
in that Jed episode where they're going
to they're gonna break the dam they're
gonna drown that neighborhood full of I
mean no soldiers just families are the
Fire Nation and they stand up and said
no this is not right these people have
done nothing ZAR people just trying to
live their lives but I agree we have an
act we haven't actually gone into a
point where we just see the kids of the
fire nation you know sometimes we'll see
a family here they are like a fair or
something but this is specific not
associated and they're like any other
how the Fire Nation comes to be you know
I mean yeah how their lesson is very
clear is that these kids all start out
normal and then basically go through
boarding school hell and come out these
nationalistic jingoistic fire tossing
maniacs you know which is what Seok is
always saying
um so I thought that was really great
and the dance things kind of silly but I
mean they they admit that I think one of
them says in the game that just sounds I
think it was so good that just sounds
silly like you know but I think it's
also proving a point which is so much of
what and this comes into play later
so much of what Aang is
instructed to do is basically kill the
Fire Lord take up the fire nation this
mad and he's figuring out well maybe
there's another way you know maybe I can
plant the seeds you know of revolution
in these kids maybe if they can just
learn to cut loose a little you know
maybe something will spread maybe it
won't I think there is and stuff like
this is important because a mistake that
so many people make especially when
they're emotional I you know and I may
get to and I know you may get to what
we've all made it is that you know
outside of just like necessarily a
prejudice or something when you look at
a group of people like you know people
who like this or people that like that
they're all this well they say they want
this but really they want that when you
get down to it you there's no way to
properly capture that because it's
always gonna be nothing but a ton of
people with a ton different opinions and
there may be patterns but there's still
individual people and when you say one
group once this one group wants that I
want it you can't ever sum up exactly
what one group is cuz it's always going
to be a ton of different people and it's
hard to sum up even what one person is
so episodes like this I think are very
very important because as you said it
doesn't just blaze away will improve on
hair so one this is one the most
important episodes of the season and
that's why I mean that you know we can
joke about me like oh it's just
Footloose and like but you get past that
one point and there's a whole ton of
stuff going on I know I wish and it
gives you a history of a fire and and I
know I know it needs to be silly and I
get that I wish it could but I wish it
could've been more silly like some of
the other episodes have been silly like
there's a there's a funny or silly in
there somewhere and then maybe you touch
more of a clever silly but but this is a
this is still a good silly you know the
other interesting thing it does is it
gives us a sense of fire nation culture
which I didn't mention in the last
episode but one thing I noticed and I
could be wrong about this but it seems
like the show is drawing on for kind of
specific cultures for each of the
elements you know waterbending to me is
very in ulid eskimo siberian sort of
shaman base you know the north
the airbenders seem very Tibetan
Buddhists as maybe Shaolin monks um the
earth Kingdom to me I didn't mention
this last episode but it's very Chinese
to me like right down to the bureaucracy
that's trying to keep everything secret
you know that just strikes me as just
being very sort of Chinese in nature
what design the size of it the fact that
it'll yeah yeah and then the Fire Nation
I mean maybe I'm wrong in this whenever
I look at them and particularly the
indoctrination um
Japanese like when I look at it with
their Navy and the whole indoctrination
or the focus on and the aspect of the
schools remind me of you know what was
going on basically like in fascist Japan
you know the the 30s and you know that's
like you we like the Japanese no I don't
know problem that still it is at all
ya know it's a part of history that
happened oh and I think they're actually
kind of referencing that I mean what
nation is not head of dark time you know
in their history so but I mean they're
all drawing from certain time periods
and certain and like I think they're
they're trying to correlate you know
what the Fire Nation is doing with what
pre-war or World War two Japan was
looking like you know where you had all
of these kids being you know taught
things like for the good of the state
you know and I mean the Germans were
doing the same thing but this isn't as
guess it this seems servelet Japanese
but sort of emphasis on like Nazi
Germany honestly I mean it's I'm like
again I'm sure even Japan the darkest
ages have gone through something similar
but it's like I read a lot of Nazi ISM
only we're doing the same thing it was
all about the state is the highest honor
you have to serve your country you know
I I mean to look at I mean we'd to some
extent we're doing some of it to you
look of propaganda we had at the time
you know sure um so it just seems to be
drawing a connection I said Japanese
because it maybe they have the fat they
seem to be I mean you could argue that a
lot of them are island nations but then
in particular it seems to be an island
nation with a very modern Navy
everything sort of technology
I'm an era in history and the fact that
it's an Asian culture so and I get my
money off of a red you know because I
also think that like you know the other
thing I think very much is sort of like
it sounds weird but like Klingon I think
we serve agree to that Klingon is very
much very Japanese too because there's a
sort of Bushido sort of code of the
samurai yeah I mean just an emphasis on
honor that seems to be a big part you
know Zuko it's not going back for power
he's going back for honor and he now he
has the power and the eye but he he
feels like he doesn't have the honor
something still missing I'm not saying
it's modern Japanese I'm just saying but
it's tapping into those you know sort of
cultures we've had throughout history
and they all seem agen base to me what
in this world it's you know so that's
why I tend to think of Japan here's
something else here's something else I
think is very important
that I think they're playing out with
the exception of maybe the air Kingdom
because we haven't quite seen enough of
them especially cuz they're big I really
wanting to well well it's such because
they're gone out to the practically
extinct is that all the nations they've
shown these large problems with these
nations with the you know with the
waterbag nation you serve get this that
they are kind of sex that they won't
train women and then women and those are
the only two places you know and then
there now that we get wiggle room there
with the earth and the earth nation the
cover-ups and the government controlling
everything without you even realizing in
the secrecy and of course with the fire
nation you know define militarism yeah
the military things and just going too
far so it's one of those things where I
do wonder if they focused at one point
more on what the the air nation or the
wind nation well whatever it's called
I'm like a there's a found maybe we was
seeing the flaws there - I think it's
implied actually um generally looking at
it it seems implied to me that the air
nation is sort of um hermit-like
yeah we did get that one yeah I'm gonna
take him away from his from his friends
and everything because and they would
not let him be a kid I mean which is
very debatable whether or not that was
you
I think is and this is a criticism of of
certain sects of Buddhism or Indian a
Hindi philosophy which is the cons of
withdrawing from the world like that is
that is a criticism sometimes levied
against that sort of you know basically
those philosophies or religions and and
when I think I think that's definitely
something that you could argue that
maybe their fatal flaw because they're
withdrawing from the world they are
pacifistic they seem very agrarian not
that much into technology and they get
their asses handed to him you know on on
top of that that episode where one of
the temples is taken over by the
whatever the inventor and those people
and so if an egg is really like what is
going on here no not cool and he has to
be taught that these people need to
survive as well and it's sort of this
was the original ideology that maybe
they were starting to sort of turn
against - so your rights are cutting
yourself away from the world you're
cutting yourself away from people and
helping people something out and there
may because since this shows drawing so
much from Asian history and it there may
be a correlation there you know between
you have the argument you know between
the Chinese and the Tibetan Buddhist you
know the Chinese sort of rolled right in
and now all of the Tibetan Buddhists are
either living under Chinese rule or
spread out in exile you know perhaps
like what could have happened to the our
kingdom I don't know if that's
intentional or not but you know what you
could probably make that argument a
bottom-line what what I do like is that
and essentially what those shows can be
down to two is that there's not one evil
like if you're on this side evil with it
no these are still people these are
still humans is when things are thrown
out of balance through one way or
another people wanting more or wanting
less or whatever and that's essentially
what aang is trying to do is trying to
bring back the balance and it's not a
simple good versus evil and it's very
more you of those cultures it doesn't
just say they're the enemy or even if
it's like we're gonna make peace with
the enemy this wholeness or so human
gave you a culture to attach yourself to
a culture that you're gonna explore more
and yeah in the rest of the series and
it makes them human and I don't see that
a lot in cartoons it drives me nuts no
but I told the film
we don't know what's going on with those
stormtroopers they may have perfectly
nice family lives I mean I mean I
guarantee like just goes up and that's
it
yeah I mean a guarantee most of the
summer films you'll see here they're at
pg-13 or R I mean they're not gonna go
nearly into as much unity give a crack
yeah well and they're not going to
nearly as much humanity as this show is
for families so yeah again in my opinion
that actually makes the family show way
more adult because they had balls to
talk about it so and it has the time it
has the intelligence it has the talent
so I thought it was a great episode
oh no it's dope I know that was bad I
just said that I think some other silly
owns it better or funnier um so yeah
it's still good episode enjoy it and uh
yeah but just he had the next one